of different outcomes as well as checks
and controls that doesn't show to me any
clarity whatsoever in that document and
there is not even any mention of the
famed frictionless trade that was
promised in the checkers proposals the
former brexit secretary that's one of
the former brexit secretaries promised a
detailed precise and substantive
document the government spectacularly
failed to deliver it so Mr Speaker I can
confirm this that Labour will vote
against this deal tonight
[Music]
labour will vote against it because it's
a bad deal for this country and as we
have heard over the past week members in
all parties including many in the
conservative party will join us in
rejecting this botched and damaging deal
and I welcome the fact there is a clear
majority to reject any No Deal outcome
the amendment to the finance bill last
week demonstrated the will of the house
on rejecting the danger and it is a
danger of a No Deal outcome that would
cause such chaos to so many people
across this country but Mr Speaker it's
not enough for the house to vote against
the deal before us and against No Deal
we also have to be for something so mr.
speaker
so mr. speaker in the coming days it is
vital that this house has the
opportunity to debate and vote on the
way forward to consider all the options
available the overwhelming majority of
the House voted to respect the result of
the referendum and therefore voted to
trigger article 50 so I say this to our
negotiating partners in the European
Union if Parliament votes down this deal
then reopening negotiations should not
and cannot be ruled out we understand
why after two frustrating years of
negotiations this I'm saying to the
European Union you would want this
resolved but this Parliament our
Parliament here has only one duty to
represent the interests of the people of
this country and the deal negotiated by
the government does not meet the needs
of the people of this country the people
of Britain including many European Union
Nationals who have made their lives here
these are people who've contributed to
our country have contributed to our
economy and to our public services
including our National Health Service
and those people are now anxious and
having no faith in this government to
manage the process of settled stasis
fairly or efficiently and the early
pilots of the scheme are very far from
encouraging the Prime Minister claimed
that this is a good deal and so
confident was she of that that she
refused to publish the government's
legal advice but her government's own
economic assessment clearly tells us it
is
bad deal it's a product mr. speaker of
two years of botched negotiations in
which the government spent more time
arguing with itself and in its own
cabinet than it did in negotiating with
the European Union it's not only on
brexit that they have failed under this
government mr. speaker more people are
living in poverty including
mr. speaker I'm talking of the poverty
of half a million more children who've
been moved into poverty while this
government's been in office I'm also
talking of those that have been forced
into rough sleeping and homelessness
which has risen every year too many
people are stuck in low-paid an insecure
work too many people are struggling to
make ends meet and falling deeper and
deeper into personal debt on credit
cards and loan sharks nothing in this
brexit deal and nothing on offer from
this government will solve that
that is why labor believes that a
general election would be the best
outcome for the country
if this deal
if this deal is rejected tonight we meet
mr. speaker to keep in mind that the
vast majority of the people of this
country don't think of themselves as
remain us or leave us whether they voted
leave or remain two and a half years ago
they all of them are concerned about
their future and it's their concerns
this house must be able to answer and
meet so Mr Speaker I hope that tonight
this house votes down this deal and then
we move to a general election so the
people
mr. speaker so the people Oh nobody's
going to shout the right honourable
gentleman down just his neighbor he will
shout the Prime Minister down all
they're doing by causing me to intervene
is taking time away not necessary rather
foolish thoroughly counterproductive
Jeremy Corbyn so mr. speaker the people
need to be able to take back control and
a general election would give them the
opportunity to decide who their MPs were
who their government was and who was
negotiating on their behalf
and it would give that new government a
mandate and the mandate that is needed
to break the deadlock that has been
brought to this house by this government
but first mr. speaker
but first Mr Speaker I asked this of the
house vote against this deal vote
against this deal because we've had a
very long and very detailed debate in
this house more members have spoken in
the debate in this debate than almost
any other debate I can remember they've
given a heartfelt analysis of this deal
and a very large number have asked I've
said why they will vote against this
deal quite simply mr. speaker this deal
is bad for our economy
a bad deal for our democracy and a bad
deal for this country I asked a house
tonight to do the right thing
reject this deal reject this deal
because of the harm it would do and show
that we as MPs are speaking up for the
people that we represent who recognize
this deal is dangerous for this country
and bad for them their living standards
and for our collective future
[Applause]
mr. mr. speaker
mr. speaker this debate this debate has
lasted some eight days over fifty four
hours with speeches of powerful
sincerity from over 200 honorable and
right honourable members it has been
historic for our Parliament and for our
country
we have heard contributions from every
perspective looking at all aspects of
this complex and vital question we've
seen this house at its most passionate
and vigorous and I thank everyone who
has contributed no one watching this
debate can be in any doubt about the
strength of this House of Commons as the
fulcrum of our democracy this is a
debate this is a debate about our
economy and security the livelihoods of
our constituents and the future for our
children and for generations to come
it goes to the heart of our Constitution
and no one should forget that it is a
democratic process that has got us to
where we are today in 2015 my party
stored on an election manifesto that had
as a centerpiece the promise of an
in-out referendum on the UK's membership
of the European Union the British people
responded by electing a Conservative
government to follow through on that
promise
that is what we did when this house
voted overwhelmingly to hold the
referendum and put the choice in the
hands of the British people indeed 470
current members voted in favour of it
and only 32 opposed it that campaign was
keenly fought it caught the public
imagination like few campaigns before it
turnout was 72% higher than for any
national poll for a quarter of a century
and while not overwhelming the result
was clear and it was decisive
something this house accepted when we
voted overwhelmingly to trigger article
50 436 current members voted to do so
only 85 opposed
Parliament gave the people a choice we
set the clock ticking on our departure
and tonight we will determine whether we
move forward with a wreath drol
agreement that honors the vote and sets
us on course for a better future the
responsibility of each and every one of
us at this moment is profound for this
is an historic decision that will set
the future of our country for
generations so what are the alternatives
that present themselves first we could
decide it's all too difficult and give
up either by revoking article 50 or
passing the backpack to the British
people in a second referendum but I
believe we have a duty to deliver on the
democratic decision of the British and
to do so in a way that brings our
country together a second referendum
would lead instead to further division
there'd be no agreement to the question
let alone the answer it would say to the
people we were elected to serve that we
were unwilling to do what they had
instructed
now the second possible outcome is that
we leave on the 29th of March without a
deal but I don't believe that's what the
British people voted for because they
were told that if they voted to leave
they could still expect a good trading
relationship with the European Union and
neither would it be the best outcome our
deal delivers certainty for businesses
with the time limited implementation
[Applause]
No Deal means no implementation period
our deal protects the rights of EU
citizens living in the UK and UK
citizens living in the EU so they can
carry on their lives as before
No Deal means no reciprocal agreement to
protect those citizens rights our deal
delivers the deepest hot security
partnership in the EU s-- history so our
police and security services can
continue to work together with their
European partners to keep all our people
safe
No Deal means no such security
partnership and our deal delivers the
foundations for an unprecedented
economic relationship with the EU but
it's more ambitious that is really
rather a noisy and unseemly atmosphere
and that has now resumed it must stop
the Prime Minister must be heard RTL
delivers the foundations for an
unprecedented economic relationship with
the EU but it's more ambitious than
anything they have ever entered into
with the third country it will give us
the benefits of trading with the
European Union and the ability to forge
new trade deals in our own right No Deal
means those new trade deals come at the
expense of a trade deal with Europe not
in addition to it so while it is
categorically wrong to suggest that our
country could not ultimate ultimately
make a success of No Deal
it is equally wrong to suggest that this
is the best outcome now third there is
the path advocated by the leader of the
Opposition and we've heard it again of
calling a general election but today's
vote is not about what's best for the
leader of the Opposition
it is about what is best for the country
[Applause]
and at the end of a general election
whatever the result the choices facing
us will not have changed it will still
be it will still be no brexit leaving
with no deal or leaving with a deal and
there's no guarantee that an election
would make the parliamentary arithmetic
any easier all it would gain is two more
months of uncertainty and division in
2017 the two main parties both stood on
manifestos that pledged to deliver the
result of the referendum they got over
80 percent of the vote people had the
opportunity to vote for a second
referendum by supporting the Liberal
Democrats in 2017
seven
just seven percent of voters
did so
it is the job of Parliament to deliver
on the promises made at the last
election not to be seeking a new one now
some suggest some suggests there's a
fourth option to agree that we should
leave with the deal on the 29th of March
but to vote this deal down in the hope
of going back to Brussels again and
negotiating an alternative deal but no
such alternative deal exists the
political declaration sets the framework
for the future relationship and the next
phase of negotiations will be our chance
to shape that relationship but we cannot
begin those talks unless or until we
agree the terms of our withdrawal and
the European Union will not agree to any
other deal for that withdrawal so having
ruled out all of these options were left
with one to vote for this deal tonight
one that delivers on the core tenets of
brexit taking back control of our
borders laws money trade and fisheries
but in a way that protects jobs ensures
our security and honors the integrity of
our United Kingdom one that strikes a
fair balance between the hopes and
desires of all our fellow citizens those
who voted to leave and those who voted
to stay in and if we leave with the deal
I'm proposing I believe we can lay the
foundations from which to build a better
Britain and as Prime Minister I would
not stand at this despatch box and
recommend a course of action but I do
not believe is in the best interest of
our country and our future
and there are there are differences in
this house today but I believe we can
come together as we go forwards and let
me reassure anyone who's in any doubt
whatsoever the government will work
harder at taking Parliament with us and
as we move
[Applause]
as we move on to the next phase of
negotiations we will be looking to work
with Parliament to seek that consensus
but Mr Speaker let me turn to the most
contentious element of our deal the
Northern Ireland protocol I said
[Applause]
my right honourable friend the Prime
Minister knows that what concerns many
of us is the possibility of the
permanent nature of the Northern Ireland
backstop may I refer her to my amendment
be on the order paper which says sets a
deadline for that backstop and my Oscar
what is the attitude of the government
to my amendment can I thank my honorable
bright honorable friend for the question
he's asked and for the work that he has
been doing to try to find a way through
on this particular issue and I know he
spent a long time consulting with
international lawyers on this issue the
government isn't able to accept the
amendment that has been selected that my
right only friend has put down it has
been selected tonight because we have a
different opinion and a different
interpretation of the Vienna Convention
but I note that my rival friend has put
down an alternative proposals in
relation to this issue the government is
willing to look at creative solutions
and we'll be happy to carry on working
with friends
that particular issue I said I would
turn
I said
I said I would turn to the Northern
Ireland the house was calm itself Zen
restraint patience here the Prime
Minister I set out the government's
position in detail on my statement yet
in my statement yesterday so I'm not
going to go over it again but the key
thing to remember is this isn't a
commitment we're making to the European
Union it's a commitment to the people of
Northern Ireland and Ireland that they
will be able to carry on living their
lives as they do today it's about saying
that whatever happens when we leave the
EU we will honor the Belfast agreement
its success has been built on allowing
people from both communities in Northern
Ireland to feel that their identities
are respected under the principle of
consent for many people in Northern
Ireland that means having a seamless
land border between the UK and Ireland
which is also essential for their
economy for others that remains fully
respecting the fact that Northern
Ireland is an intrinsic part of the
United Kingdom no one wants to see the
return of a hard border and as a proud
unionist I share the concerns of members
who are determined that we do not
undermine the strength of our United
Kingdom but it is it is not enough
simply to make these assertions we have
to put in place arrangements that
deliver those ends and it's not just as
simple as some would like it to be so as
Prime Minister for the whole UK it's my
duty to provide a solution that works
for the people of Northern Ireland the
answer lies in agreeing our future
economic relationship but we need an
insurance policy to guarantee there will
be no hard border if that future
relationship is not in place by the end
of the implementation period
I'll give way to the leader of the
democratic movement very very grateful
to the Prime Minister for giving way and
would she agree that whatever one's view
on this withdrawal agreement and
whatever arguments the people deploy
that we should not be using the peace or
the political process in Northern
Ireland as arguments for voting for this
deal or voting against it would she
agree that that is completely and
utterly out of order make that clear
for all of our cabinet colleagues as
well gentlemen I think everybody
everybody across this house is committed
to ensuring that we maintain the
arrangements of the Belfast Good Friday
Agreement that we also ensure that we
maintain the many benefits that have
come from the peace process in Northern
Ireland and that should not be disrupted
and that not should be should not be
affected in any sense but I also say
that whatever future relationship is
going to be negotiated or people want to
see being negotiated that insurance
policy is essential any of the other
proposals Canada Norway any number of
variations of those models all of them
require the insurance policy and that is
the so-called backstop and no no
backstop simply means No Deal now and
for the foreseeable future and I don't
want to see anybody being able to
exploit No Deal
and bringing doubt about the future of
our union as a result of that and let's
remember if I may say to this house what
the withdrawal agreement does deliver
for the people of Northern Ireland an
implementation period certainty for
businesses protection of citizens rights
certainty to thousands of families no
heart border unfettered access to
position EU markets protection of a
single electricity market across the
island of Ireland securing energy supply
in Northern Ireland continued security
cooperation with our European allies but
the Police Service of Northern Ireland
say is essential and above all the
protection of the historic Belfast Good
Friday Agreement the deal we have puts
our union first now let me turn to the
contribution of the leader of the
opposition characteristic a
characteristic speech a characteristic
his whole approach to brexit long long
criticism and short on coherence
these claims that he'll be able to
renegotiate the deal in a matter of
weeks get a drastically different
outcome and despite the European Union
making clear that's impossible but
everything he does is designed to avoid
taking any difficult decisions saying
one thing to one group and another thing
to another in the general election he
said his manifesto in his manifesto
freedom of movement will end on Sunday
he said I'm not against the free
movement of people when asked for that
corrects it in a German newspaper he
said we can't stop it the referendum
took place article fifties being
triggered in his speech at Wakefield
last week and again this evening he said
a second referendum was an option on the
table he says labour would run an
independent trade policy but he wants to
join the customs union
he says he's opposed to No Deal but he
says he's opposed to withdrawal
agreement on the back stop without which
there is no deal so the question is what
is his position because he has failed in
his in his responsibility
his responsibility to provide a credible
alternative to the government of the day
by pursuing from the start a cynical
course designed to serve his own
interest
not the national interest he is
forfeited the right to demand loyalty
from those of his MPs who take a more
pragmatic view because he doesn't care
whether we leave or not with a deal or
not as long as he can maximize
disruption and uncertainty and the
likelihood of general election
and I hope that members opposite who
faithfully pledged to their constituents
that they would respect the result of
the referendum but they think carefully
before voting against a deal which
delivers brexit and I hope that those
who fear leaving without a deal whose
constituents rely on manufacturing jobs
think very carefully about rejecting a
deal that is the only guaranteed way to
take no deal off the table mr. speaker
mr. speaker this is the most significant
vote that any of us will ever be part of
in our political careers
after after all the debate all the
disagreement all the division the time
has now come for all of us in this house
to make a decision a decision that will
define our country for decades to come a
decision that will determine the future
for our constituents their children and
their grandchildren a decision that each
of us will have to justify and live with
for many years to come we know the
consequences of voting for this deal
they are laid out in black and white in
the pages of the withdrawal agreement
but no one who votes against this deal
will be able to tell their constituents
what real-world outcome they voted for
because a vote against this deal is a
vote for nothing more than uncertainty
division and the very real
and I'm very great I'm very grateful for
the Prime Minister forgiving me Prime
Minister on any of the analysis of
brexit economic growth will be lower
than staying in the United in the
European Union well the Prime Minister
not realized on the basis of the
knowledge and on the fact that people
are going to lose opportunities as a
consequence of brexit the alternative is
to extend article 50 google could give
the people the see let's act in all our
emphasis on the basis of the information
that we now have gentlemen Parliament
gave the British people a choice
Parliament the government of the time
all parties all those campaigning in
that referendum were absolutely clear
but whatever the decision of that
referendum it would be respected by
government and by Parliament
and I believe that we have a duty to
deliver on that referendum vote and to
do so in a way that does protect
people's jobs and protects our security
and protects our union a vote against
this deal is a vote for nothing more
than uncertainty division and the very
and the very real risk of No Deal or No
wrecks it at all and it doesn't it
doesn't have to be that way tonight we
can choose certainty over uncertainty we
can choose unity over division we can
choose we can choose we can choose to
deliver on our promise to the British
people not break that promise and
endanger trust in politics for a
generation because as members of
parliament we have a duty to serve not
our own self-interest nor that of our
parties but the people we were elected
to represent
it is the people of this country that we
were sent here to serve the people of
this country who queued up at polling
stations who cast their ballots so they
might put their faith in us it is the
people of this country who entrusted us
with the sacred right to build for them
and their children and grandchildren
the brighter future they expect and
deserve and if we act in the national
interest and back this deal tonight then
tomorrow we can begin to build that
future together if we act in the
national interest and back this deal
tonight we can build a country that
works for everyone
together we can show the people we serve
that their voices have been heard that
their trust was not misplaced that our
politics can and does deliver that
politicians can rise above our
differences and come together to do what
the people asked of us that is the test
history is set for us today it will
determine the future of our country for
generations
we each have a solemn responsibility to
deliver brexit and take this country
forward and with my whole heart I call
on this house to discharge that
responsibility too together and I
commend this motion to the house
[Applause]
under the order of the house of the 4th
of December and the 9th of January I
must now put the questions necessary to
dispose of proceedings on the European
Union withdraw all motion as I explained
the sequence earlier it should now be
familiar to colleagues I begin by
inviting Jeremy Corbyn the leader of the
opposition to move amendment a not moved
I turn now to the second of the
amendments that in the name of the
leader of the Scottish National Party
mr. Ian Blackford amendment K not moved
mr. speaker thank you I turned to the
right honourable general the member for
Gainsborough to move if he so wishes
amendment B in view of the positive
response from the PM have not moved very
well and finally I invite mr. John Baron
to move amendment F I beg to move
[Music]
amendment s be made as many as other
opinions day I of the country now
I think they I think the nose habit
is it is the honorable gentleman
persisting now persistency order I know
what I'm doing the key point is
persistence
if the Honorable Jota order if the
honorable gentleman wishes to press his
amendment he is entitled to do so
oh yes he is oh yes he is I'll be the
judge of that
the question is that the amendment be
made I'll say it once Ward's been is a
little bit say I the country now
[Applause]